what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so getting back into our whole DC
rebirth discussion we pick up with green
arrow and again this coverage of green
arrow and a lot of these earlier stories
well they did happen a while ago this
was really designed you just kind of
flesh out our DC rebirth playlist so
that people kind of get a mixed bag of
all the different things that are out
there and we're doing that
chronologically is that way you know we
could kind of go through and we could
say okay here's a wide array of
different things and it's also in
chronological order so you see what
characters were doing and what other
characters are doing and what teams were
doing all leading up to some of the big
stories like dark nights metal and you
know Superman reborn and different
things like that but when we did our
first video on Green Arrow we really
began to have this conversation about
the nature of Oliver Queen and the cool
thing about Oliver is that in a lot of
ways he's not designed to be like Bruce
Wayne in Green Arrow comics he's totally
different from what you see in the TV
show and that's one of the reasons why
the reception to the TV show was largely
mixed you know when it came to the
personality of Oliver Queen in terms of
the show it did have a season I think it
was season 3 where it was just kind of
like and it did not do very well I
actually quit the show because of that
for a while and now it's bounce back I
just finished season 4 I think it was
reason 5 whichever one had prometheus
and that was so good but we talked about
in the first video how there was an
organization called the ninth circle and
because the fact that it was the first
story arc following the Green Arrow
rebirth one shot which is to say DC
coming out and saying here's where
everything stands with Oliver Queen and
Green Arrow that story largely dealt
with like two or three things the first
thing was a group called the ninth
circle and the ninth circle was really
nothing more than just a group of super
powerful and wealthy people who wore
masks to keep their identities hidden
and they operated behind the scenes and
I mean they were involved in everything
drug smuggling trading of people and so
on and so forth all kinds of things that
went on into that and the idea of Oliver
Queen was to find a way to take him down
and that was really about it now it also
went into the introduction of a sister
that he didn't know he had and different
things along those lines but which of
course will probably be fleshed out
later on down the line but the big thing
to take away from this really the
biggest sticking point when it came to
the beginning of Green Arrow rebirth
with the first story arc was the
introduction of a relationship between
Oliver Queen and black Canary now at the
end of that story the end of the last
video we really kind of just dealt with
the idea that the ship had been blown up
you know and everything had kind of gone
awry and you know we ended up having
Oliver Queen just kind of landing back
on the same island he was on before
where he basically learned and honed the
skills that he's gained that it
such a formidable Archer and combatant
and so again this really kind of follows
that in the sense that he's basically
dealing with giant cybernetic bears
benjamin percy man you you confused me
at times that you're an amazing writer
but you confuse me at times
the fact remains you know oliver kind of
dealing with this whole thing this is
exactly what green arrow is about it's
designed to be just fun it's not
designed to be like Batman it's not
designed to be dark and brooding this is
the comic you read when you just want to
have a good time now of course the other
half of this is that he is largely
absent from Black Canary at the moment
now of course that's rectified almost
immediately she basically shows up on
shore she's like I promise I'm not a
mirage I'll promise I'm not like the
best looking Mirage ever I'm actually
here let's do it let's jump in the water
get naked and do what makes us happy but
the other thing to keep in mind about
this is that in the early days when new
52 first launched when DC basically
wanted you to treat Green Arrow like
they never published him before there
was a lot of backlash to the early
stories because people who were fans of
Oliver Queen recognized that there was
kind of a other half of him that was
missing in the form of Black Canary now
the goal of DC with regards to Dinah was
to largely flush her character out let's
put her in a circumstance where we can
basically focus on her as opposed to
focus on her as like a sidekick slash
wife of Oliver Queen and it kind of
worked to a degree I mean you know for
those people who were fans of birds of
prey they really enjoyed it but for
people who were fans of Green Arrow it
was like look this isn't how it's
supposed to be they're supposed to be
together and there's a long history of
that there were huge moments there were
some very big moments longbow hunters by
Mike Grell the vertigo run of Green
Arrow by Mike Grell all those things
dealt with like these huge moments in
the relationship between the two you
know the birth of Connor Hawke and the
eventual death of Connor Hawke I mean
all these things went in select
developing their characters as
fundamental people it made the
relationship stronger and then it
actually ended up shattering their
relationship later on down the line but
there were great things that went you
know went into the development of these
two in fact there was actually a point
in the publication history of Green
Arrow where he was getting with the mom
and the daughter at the same time it's
actually kind of messed up but again
that's that's the basis behind this now
the other part of this comes with the
character of John Diggle now John Diggle
really made his appearance in 2013 and I
want to say was Green Arrow issue number
24 it was during the Jeff Lemire and
Andre Sorrentino run of Green Arrow
which by the way is amazing it is so
good we might go back and cover that one
day
now John Diggle being rolled into the
coming books that was similar just kind
of an appeal to the show and that was
one of the big things that really
polarizes audiences when it comes to
comics I mean in this instance he runs
them to these giant bears just like
everybody else the difference is that
instead of him overcoming the Bears like
Oliver Queen did he's alternately
captured by some woman with like a
really screwed up looking face and one
of those ninth circle coins in her eyes
basically those individuals who are
brought into the ninth circle have the
entire side of their face scarred and
then they have a coin thrown in their
eye and it really just kind of signifies
their allegiance to the group but the
other half of this is also remember
Oliver Queen's more or less been ousted
from his own company you know Broderick
has really kind of gone out for him and
in that whole thing so again there are
some themes that are going on but
because of the fact that this is like a
two issues story and it's really just
kind of focuses on Black Canary and and
Green Arrow in isolation
we're largely gonna emphasize that with
with Oliver Queen and black Canary
spending time with each other this is
cool this is actually a really really
cool moment between these two characters
because again when new 52 first started
they never met they were never together
they were never in a relationship and
again because of the fact that there was
so much history before a new 52 started
there was a lot of disappointment there
and a lot of people wanted to see that
this is designed to kind of bring that
back they weren't together before but
they're together now so it's you know
it's better to have it now than not have
it at all and it works for most Green
Arrow fans I mean it's it comes together
really really well and in truth it's
actually pretty interesting because what
this does is it doesn't really retread
water I mean it retreads water insofar
as Oliver Queen and black Canary are
together but it doesn't really reach red
water in this sense of the story arcs
well if you're picking up green arrow
for the very first time or if you've
been reading Green Arrow for years
leading up to the launch of new 52 what
you get is basically hey they're back
together again but you kind of get like
a story of like when they're meeting for
the first time things like that for
Green Arrow Black Canary fans this is
what new features should have been when
it first kicked off but of course you
know with regards to John Diggle and the
fact that they come across as campfire
this leads to them kind of leaping into
action and saying okay so it diggle's
here too and then jumping into it now
into this discussion of John Diggle this
is pretty cool because John Diggle was
originally of course as we know part of
the TV show he was never originally part
of DC Comics it was never that way
instead
him being rolled into the comics was an
extension of the show and again that's
why I said that's kind of polarizing is
because when it comes to you introducing
characters fans don't really want to be
duped like hey check out this character
who just happens to be in TV show
wouldn't you really like him if he was
in the comics you know and so the result
was that resent
John Diggle was not initially huge now
it got to be pretty cool you know just
because of the fact that his character
was flushed out and it was it was really
really interesting the way it was done
of course you know having Green Arrow
and having Black Canary tried to track
down John Diggle also results in them
coming across what looks like an Inuit
which is pretty interesting you know
some guy just kind of living in the
mountains and and off doing his own
thing now of course with the the three
of them working together and also
because of the fact that they broke the
leg of this guy you know this of course
leads to his bunker we end up finding
out he's the one that's got all these
cybernetic bears and things like that
running around but the cool thing about
this is that this is not a designed to
be some great big huge thing right it's
not like Benjamin Percy's like oh man
there's a survivor of the ninth circle
and now they have to find a thousand
soldiers it's nothing like that this is
a two issue story arc it's largely a
filler comic to be honest and all this
really does is hit on the idea that
there is this married couple this man
this woman were effectively together and
they ended up going to different ways
but the reason for that was because in
her mind the only way to really begin to
expand their you know island culture and
their tribe and so on what's to become a
bigger part of the world and originally
Oliver Queen's father had actually
approached her wanting to set up some
sort of transatlantic you know train
system and then following that they were
met by the Eden by the ninth circle and
said look your Island is out in the
middle of nowhere we can run drugs
people the whole nine yards through this
transit system and no one will be able
to find us that they won't know where
we're going it'll just head off to one
location and it's the easiest way to get
things anywhere in the world the result
is that where the husband basically
walked away and said no we don't need to
have any involvement with that she went
along with it and so what this did music
created a rift of sorts they basically
put these characters in a situation
where they were looking at the idea of
their entire circumstance for tutoring
from two different perspectives and this
is designed to mirror the Black Canary
Oliver Queen relationship again because
of the fact of their marriage eventually
came crashing down and really went to
pieces this is design to basically say
that there is such a thing in
relationships called irreconcilable
differences not only that this does have
act you know After Effects for like the
recklessness of Oliver Queen and that's
kind of the cool thing about this is
Ollie is in a lot of ways just kind of
out there doing his thing and sure his
comics are kind of jokey but the thing
to keep in mind is that at the end of
the day he is a superhero people look at
and you know look to him for protection
for the means to defend themselves or
the very least to show them a better way
and where he shows up here alongside
Black Canary and alongside John Diggle
and they literally sort like
everything you know and and just you
know kind of blowing everything up the
result is that it basically leads to
like the destruction of this whole
facility and the problem with this is
that the couple actually turns directly
on Oliver Queen and black Canary kinda
like you guys took away our ability to
choose you guys took away our ability to
decide what direction we end up going in
that's the significance of all this is
because initially they could kind of you
know reconcile their differences and try
to find a way that works try to fix
everything and so on and so forth give
their tribes sort of back on track
especially considering the ninth circle
has been destroyed so there's really no
one kind of lingering in the background
pulling the strings making sure they do
what it is that they're supposed to do
the other half of this is that it also
again kind of brings this idea together
that there is always room to basically
fix things there is always the ability
to make things right the way that
they're supposed to be and so again this
really is kind of like Benjamin Percy
hitting back on the nose of the old
stories of Black Canary Green Arrow the
times of their marriage work the times
that came crashing down all that kind of
stuff and basically throwing in disrupt
relief this idea that there will be
trials and tribulations but they'll come
to points where they feel like it's just
not working but ultimately they kind of
have to pull it back together and make
it happen so again it is a filler issue
there's not a whole lot to go on here
you know it's just kind of a story where
some things happen and then they're done
and they're like well let's go to
Seattle and then that's it now again all
this is really kind of like a journey
thing Queen industries taken over by
Broderick the whole idea of Oliver's to
get back and basically take his company
back you know I mean that's that's
really all this is is just kind of
following this journey leading up to
like that final destination but along
the way we get these small little
tidbits here and there you know we get
these small little moments Green Arrow
and these guys kind of you know dealing
with various conflicts and making
mistakes and screwing up and all that
kind of good stuff you know trying to
get the relationship between the three
of them to work and all those
interesting intriguing things but
without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here two comments explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you